three years ago a flood wave destroyed
270 houses here in Duque de Caxias two
people were left dead and 60 injured the
scale of the disaster became apparent
the day after looking at pictures from
back then is still hard to bear for a
janilla gonsalvez her family managed to
escape in time but they've lost
everything
Akim my second me a car this used to be
my house cuando I was V the water gushed
in here through the window we heard this
dull thud and immediately went to look
the flood wave had already washed away
everything out front we had no time at
all we just had to run him
the houses were built right next to the
river even though it often rains heavily
here the trained architect Marcia Vieira
blames poor planning in the past
Vieira who heads up the urban planning
department takes us to the center of
dukkha de cashius for city borders Rio
de Janeiro almost a million people live
here many of them commuters in the last
few decades the city has grown
exponentially lack of urban planning in
the past meant that buildings in the
city were constructed incredibly close
together
no green spaces were left everything was
built over the disaster that took place
three years ago has led to a rethink the
arrow points out to us the coastal strip
just beyond the city which is lined with
mangrove swamps tells us that this is
the first time the people have recorded
how nature benefits the city and its
people a study was funded by the German
international climate protection
initiative
thanks to this research it's now easier
to explain why certain construction
projects cannot be given planning
permission ecosystems and natural
habitats have to be given priority
everyone in the municipal authority is
playing their part now have an
instrument to shape urban planning
development is now prohibited in the
mangrove forests on the outskirts of
Duque de Caxias they're just a few
kilometers from the city center and act
as a flood barrier
Vieira shows us around this sensitive
ecosystem nature is really impressive
particularly here in the mangrove swamps
it's so powerful and this power becomes
apparent on EV tides when the creature
is living in the mud become more visible
the crabs provide a livelihood for
hundreds of families here but the
fishermen tell us that their halls are
shrinking our guide tells us that not
long ago he also used to catch oysters
and salmon in these waters look how
dirty it is here all this rubbish
floating around the mangroves are the
only things helping to combat pollution
for us fishermen the trees filter toxins
from the water and then die off weren't
for them and we really have a huge
problem the increasing pollution is
having a detrimental impact on the
environment and biodiversity it's a
development that's also a cause of
concern for city planner
Marcia Vieira
in the future the city's existence will
depend on the mangrove forests we know
that climate change is coming and the
mangroves are our bulwark against rising
sea levels Duque de Caxias is located in
a hollow even now there's a danger of
flooding the second natural environment
that the city planners now regard as
sacred is situated to the north of the
city the Atlantic forest more than
20,000 species of plants and more than
2,000 animal species live here it's our
next stop and the director of the Nature
Reserve Gisela Medeiros joins us on our
trip the Atlantic forest used to cover
large swaths of Brazil only 7% of the
original forest has survived that fair
one people pose the biggest threat to
the forest we have to communicate better
that the financial benefits of logging
pale in comparison with those of having
an intact forest
this is where the city's drinking water
comes from the rain forests also helps
cool the entire region it also provides
another valuable service that explains
its status in Marseille of the era's
master plans when it rains hard the rain
forest retains a large volume of water
and releases it into the city more
gradually it absorbs a lot of water and
slows down the outflow the rain forest
has become a lifesaver for the city's
inhabitants without it the flood wave
would have been a lot more destructive
three years ago increasingly areas close
to the river are being left undeveloped
so they can act as a floodplain we've
moved on from the phase where we were
concerned with building as much as
possible without a second thought now
when we construct a building we couple
it with a green space no one benefits if
houses are squeezed in next to each
other and people are piled on top of
each other the quality of life suffers
and it can cause disasters like it did
here we want to create a city in which
nature is a firm fixture hopefully the
city of Duque de Caxias will respect its
natural resources more in the future
it can only be in the best interests of
the people living here